ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกๆคนใส่ค่ะผู้เอกก็
ยังไม่รู้นักเรียนคนที่ 12 มาหรือยัง
ยังไม่รู้เรามีคนที่ 11 แล้ว
ครูใหญ่ค่ะผู้หญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 8 ค่ะวันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
4022 ค่ะงอกวันนี้นะคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันที่ 7 ค่ะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์
อ่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วัน
เสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9 ที่ 9 นะ
คะวันนี้เมื่อวานนี้พรุ่งนี้ตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมง
ตอนนี้เวลา
10:05 ค่ะ
10:00 นค่านาทีนะคะมีแฟน V ค่ะ
โอเคครูหญิงวันนี้
ครูเอ๋
มีหรืออะไรคะพูดโอ้ยังไม่ได้ทักนักเรียน
อ่า
นักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียน
ง่วงนอนไหมคะ
มากมายนักเรียนใส่หน้าไม่ง่วงไม่ง่วงนอน
นะไม่ค่ะ
โอเคเพราะว่า 10 โมงเนี่ยอ่ะไทยน่ะว้าว
กลางวันค่ะสว่างใช่ไหมกลางวัน
ซึ่งไทย
ประเทศอเมริกาหรือยุโรปเนี่ยกลางคืนใช่
ไหมใส่ค่ะกลางลองราคากลางคืนกลางคืนก็อาจ
จะ
ถ้า
ง่วงนอนอันเนี้ยขาว
หาวเราก็ง่วงนอนนะคะ
ไม่ง่วงนอนนะคะอะไรหรอไม่ไม่ง่วงนอน
โอเคไม่ง่วงนอนไม่ง่วงนอนก็ตาดู
หูฟัง
ธรรมะหูเนี่ยฟังค่ะเพื่อนครู
ปากพูด
ปลา 3 ใสหูฟังปากอ้ะ
ไงผู้
ฟังฟังฟังๆ
ก็ไม่ติดพูดโอเคใส่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงครูเอ๋ขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะได้ค่ะครู
เอ๋
คะ
เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะ Share  screen ค่ะ kh แอ
สเคนะคะกูอ่าก่อนหน้า
ผู้หญิงขยายได้ไหม
ขยายแล้วโอเคค่ะนักเรียนเห็นครูอะนัก
เรียนเห็นนะโอเค
คุยว่านะคะผู้หญิงค่ะอันนี้เป็นอะไรคะ
วงกลมค่ะวงกลมน้ำอ่าโอเคใส่อันนี้
ขีดขีดขีดๆ
หือ
เอกวาดโขว่าขีดขีดขีดๆเสร็จแล้วคู่หญิง
คิดว่าอะไรคะผู้ชายค่ะผู้ชายาคุยเปลี่ยน
เป็นสีดำนะมีเว็บกะสีดำครูเคสเปลี่ยนสี
เปลี่ยนลบออกลบค่ะ
โอเคโค๊ะมีวงกลมขีดขีดๆแล้วกลับ
เป็นหูคะหูผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิง
ผู้ชายค่ะผู้ชายนะคะเสี่ยเอ๋ว่าผิว
อันนี้อะไรคะ
ตาค่ะตา
จมูก
อันนี้อะไรคะ
ตากป้านะคะอ่ามีผู้ชายโอเคแล้วครูเอกก็
เว่าต่อไปวงกลม
มีหูค่ะ
มีผม
ห่มยาว 3.5 เป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายคะ
ผู้หญิงค่ะอย่าผู้หญิง
ครูเอ๋วาดผู้หญิง 1 คนผู้ชาย 1 คนนะคะผู้
หญิงค่ะผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายสองคน
มีอะไรคันรักกันค่ะ
รัฐ
รักกันนะคะผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายรักกัน
นาน 3 นาน R  R  R  E  E  D คะ
9 ปีโอเคมั้ยโอเคค่ะรักกันนาน 9 ปี 9 ปี
นะคะอ้าโอเคกูเห็นลบอันนี้นะ
สองคนก็เลยผู้แต่งงานโชว์แต่งงานกันแต่ง
งานผู้หญิงมีเพลงแต่งงานไหมคะแต่แดนแต่
แต่แต่นแตนแต๊นๆแต่ในอยู่แล้วใช่ไหมครับ
ตัวเอง
พอๆๆคลิปครึ่งชั่วโมง
แตนแตนแตนๆเดี๋ยวเวลาไป
เรียนบอกไม่ได้ฟังภาษาไทย
แต่งงาน 2 หางานแต่งงานนะคะแต่งงานเสร็จ
แล้ว
มีอะไรต่อคะ
ผู้หญิงก็
ผู้หญิงทำไมตรงนี้ธรรมดาผู้หญิงทอหน้า
ท้องตรงนี้หน้าท้อง
แม่เหล็กแบนแบนแบนแบน
แล้วบอกแบนเรียบ
แบนเรียบค่ะการแต่งงานแล้วหน้าท้องผู้
หญิงก็
เปลี่ยนหรอคะไม่แบนเรียบ
ใส่ออกมาหน้าท้องใหญ่
ทำไมคะครูหญิงผู้หญิงท้อง
ผู้หญิงท้อง
ที่นี่มี
มีเด็กอ่าอ่ะเด็ดป่ามีเด็กค่ะผู้หญิงแต่ง
งานผู้หญิงท้อง
ท้องโอเคผู้ชายไม่ท้องต่อไปท้องผู้หญิง
ท้องผู้ชายไม่ท้องโอเคผู้หญิงท้องเสร็จ
แล้วท้องนานเท่าไหร่แล้วผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
ท้อง
9 เดือน
ค่ะ
คนไทยพูดนะ 9 เดือนบางคนบอก 10 เดือน
นะอ้าธรรมดา 9 เดือน 9 ผู้หญิงก็ทำไมคะ
ผู้หญิงเจ็บโป้
เจ็บท้องค่ะท้อง 9 เดือน
เจ็บท้องเองเวลาเจ็บท้องร้องยังไงคะโอโอ้
โอ้ยโอ้โอโอ้โอ้ย
เจ็บท้องเจ็บท้องนะคะ 9 เดือน
และก็ต้องไปโรงพยาบาลเนาะค่ะชาย
ไปโรงพยาบาล
ปาบีบีบ่โรงพยาบาลที่โรงพยาบาลก็มีหมอ
เนาะ
มีคุณหมออณิ
มีหมอ
มี
นางค่ะยาบาลสาดนะคะผู้หญิงไปโรงพยาบาล
ทำไมคะไปคลอดลูกค่ะไปคลอด
สารรอดลูก
เวลาคลอดลูกผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ผิงแห่งค่ะ
อะไรนะเบ่งหรอเบเบ้งอ่ะ
เตือนพรุ่งนี้ปุ้ยปุ้ย
อันนี้เด็กไทยร้องชาลาคลอดออกมาคลอดครั้ง
ที่ 1 ร้อง
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเด็กไทย
เด็กญี่ปุ่นร้องอะไรคะ
รู๋รู้ไหมเด็กญี่ปุ่นคุณทาดาชิมิรู้ไหมคะ
เด็กญี่ปุ่น
ร้องยังไง
อ๋อๆเหงาๆเหงาๆ
ญี่ปุ่นร้อง
เพลง
ไม่เด็กไทยโอ้ย
วิกเด็กไทยอ้วน
นะคะ
รอดแล้วนะคลอดอ่ะค่ะก็ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็มี
ลูก
กวินลบนะคะสิ่งก็
ท้องไม่ใหญ่แล้วท้องไม่ใหญ่ท้องแบบท้อง
คุณของท้องท้อง
ใหญ่แล้วก็คลอดลูกก็แบต
แบน
ครัวราะอะไร
หัวเราะรู้หญิงก็
หัวเราะ
อ่ะผู้หญิงก็มีมีลูก
มีลูก
ลูกคนที่ 1 ค่ะลูกคนที่ 2 ลูกคนที่ 3 รูป
คนที่ 4
ผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายมีลูก 4 คนดูบอลค่ะ
ลูกคนที่ 1 ลูกคนที่ 1 เป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้
หญิงคะลูกคนที่ 1 เป็นผู้หญิงค่ะ
[เพลง]
ลูกคนที่ 2 เป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะผู้
ชายค่ะ
ลูกคนที่ 3 เป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะผู้
หญิงค่ะ
ลูกคนที่ 4 เป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะผู้
หญิงผู้ชายค่ะพูดดีเนาะผู้ชายผู้หญิงผู้
ชายผู้หญิงผู้ชาย
4 คนนะคะ
ผู้ชาย
ผู้หญิง
แต่งงานนะคะตัวอย่างงานแต่งงานเสร็จน่ะ
เราบอกว่าผู้ชายเป็นอะไรคะเป็นพ่อ
แต่งงานก่อนแต่งงานออนไลน์งานแต่งงานผู้
ชายเป็นอะไรเป็นเจ้าบ่าว
เป็นสามีพ่อโทรหาจะมีเสื้อแต่งงานแต่งงาน
แต่งงานเสร็จแล้ว
ปาร์ตี้ปาร์ตี้เสร็จแล้วน้ำปาร์ตี้เสร็จ
แล้วเนี่ยอ้ะเป็นอะไรนะคะ
สามีสามีอ่าอ่ะผู้หญิงเป็นอะไรคะ
ภรรยาเป็นสามีภรรยา
ค่ะเวลาปาร์ตี้แต่งงานผู้ชายเป็นเจ้าบ่าว
ผู้หญิงเป็น
เจ้าสาว 3 ใช้ตอนในปาร์ตี้ใช่ไหมคะใน
ปาร์ตี้แต่งงานอ่ะเจ้าบ่าวเจ้าสาวแต่งงาน
เสร็จแล้วผู้เป็นสามีภรรยา
ตอนนี้ 2 คนมีลูกลูกลูก 4 คนผู้ชายเป็น
อะไรคะผู้ชายเป็นพ่อผู้หญิงเป็นอะไรคะแม่
พ่อพ่อแม่อ่ะลูกคนที่ 1 ลูกคนที่สองรูปคน
ที่ 3 รูปคนที่ 4 นะคะลูก 4 คนจะเรียกผู้
ชายว่า
พ่อ
เรียกผู้หญิงว่า
แม่
พ่อแม่นะคะถ้า
ครูหญิง
อะไรคะ
นักเรียนเราแต่งงานหรือยังนะนักเรียนบาง
คนแต่งงานแล้ว
บางคนมีลูกแล้วนะคะโอเคทีนี้อะถ้าลูกโตๆ
นะคะคุณลบอันนี้ก่อนนะได้ค่ะครูเอ๋กูเห็น
โลภ - ไหล-
อ้าผู้หญิงแต่งงาน
[เพลง]
ลูกสาว
คนนี้ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะ 4 คนเนี่ยพูดพ่อพ่อแม่
พ่อก็จะเรียกลูกคนที่ 1
กับลูกคนที่ 3
ว่าอะไรนะคะลูกสาวลูกสาวแล้วลูกคนที่ 2
กับคนที่ 4 ล่ะคะ
ลูกชายอะลูกชายพ่อพ่อแม่มีลูกหมอเขากี่คน
คะมีลูกสาว 2 คนมีลูกชายกี่คน
มีลูกชายสองคนมีลูกชายลูกชาย
ลูกชาย 2 คนลูกสาวลูกสาว 2 คนนะคะที่นี้
ลูกสาวโตโตๆอายุ
28 ปี
ลูกสาวแต่งงาน
น้ำแต่งงานอ่ะ
พ่อนะคะพ่อแม่
เรียกผู้ชายคนนี้ว่าอะไรคะลูกเขยลูก
เปิดเผยแล้วน้องน้องผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยผู้
หญิงชื่อชื่อทีแล้วกันอ่ะซื้อทีนะคะ
ที่ล่ะมีน้องน้องชาย
น้องสาว
น้องชายน้อง
น้องๆสามคน
เรียกคนนี้ว่าอะไรคะพี่เขยพี่เขยนะคะลูก
เขยพี่เขยน้องเอ
ทีนี้โอเคอ่ะลูกสาวคนที่ 1 แต่งงานมีลูก
เขยลูกเขย
เรียก
เรียกคุณพ่อของทีใช่มั้ยอ้ะคุณพ่อของที
เนี่ยลูกเขยเรียกคุณพ่อ TA ว่าอะไรคะอ่ะ
โป้พ่อตา
พอตานะคะโอเคลูกเขยนะลูกเขยลูกเขยเรียก
คุณแม่ของทีว่าอะไรคะแม่ยายแม่ยายนะคะ
โอเค
ที่นี้คุยรถ
ที่แต่งงานขี่นะคะถี่ทีที่แต่งงานแล้วที
ก็มีมีลูกค่ะครูหญิงก็ AB ลูกมีลูกกี่คน
มีลูก 2 คนค่ะ
ลูกคนที่ 1 ผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะผู้ชายค่ะ
ลูกคนที่ 2 ผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะผู้หญิง
ค่ะ
งั้นทีกับแม่สามีอันนี้สามีทีนะ
ที
รักรักสามีก็มีมีรูปชายกี่คนคะมีลูกชาย
1 คนมีลูกสาวกี่คนคะมีลูกสาว 1 คน
โอเคครูหญิงคะคะ
ตอนนี้ถี่เป็นคุณแม่อ้าเราก็มีสามีสามีกู
เอกให้ชื่อบีโอเคนะค่ะมิสเตอร์ B
Mister  B เป็นคุณพ่อนะคะอ่าตัวนี้เป็น
ซี่มิสเตอร์ S ราคา
กับ
Miss
Miss  it ละมิดสิ้นอะไรดี Miss  is ดีขอ
ฝันดีโอเคตอนนี้ทีเป็นแม่บีเป็นพ่อมีลูก
ลูก 2 คนค่ะลูกสาวลูกชายลูกสาวของทีของจี
ดีพี
ของทีของทีกับบีเรียก S ว่าอะไรคะ
นา
คุณตาใช่ไหมคะคุณตาคุณตาตาโอเคคุณตาโอเค
นะคะก็ลูกสาวตุ้ยโทษค่ะ
ลูกชาย
ลูกสาว 2 คน
เรียก S ว่าคุณตาว่าคุณหน้า
ตาเหมือนๆตา
เหมือนกันได้อันเนี้ยตา
อันนี้ก็
ตาค่ะ
พูดเหมือนกันจะแล้ว
ลูกชายลูกสาวของ T  T กับบี
เรียก
ดีว่าอะไรคะคุณยายอ่ะคุณยาย
ยายโอเคไหมโอเค
ยายคุณยายโอเค
แล้วอ่ะ S มิสเตอร์ S กับมิสมิสซิสดี
เรียก
หลานสองคน
ว่าอะไรคะอ่ะ
มีหลานหลานนะคะหลานอ่า
หลานผู้ชายหลานอะไรคะ
หลานชายแล้วผู้หญิงนะคะ
หลานสาว
หลานสาวหลานชายนะคะคู๋ลบตรงนี้ก่อนเนาะ
มีเคารพสนิดนึงๆค่ะอ่ะต่อไป
ใข้
สักครู่นะคะค่ะอะคนที่ 2 ลูกลูกลูกของ S
นะคะค่ะนี่ลูกชายลูกชายของ S ชื่ออะไรดี
คะซื้อมิสเตอร์ h  r ค่ะเจ๊ตัวโตๆๆแต่ง
งาน
แต่งงานนะคะ
แต่งงานครูหญิงคะคะ
s.s.s. มหาเจเอสแล้วก็ดี
ต้องเรียกนะเรียกภรรยา
ของลูกชายว่าอะไรคะลูกสะใภ้ลูกสะใภ้นะคะ
แล้วลูกสะใภ้
ลูกสะใภ้ล่ะ
ภรรยา H ไหมคะลูกสาว
เรียก
คุณพ่อของเฮชว่าอะไรคะ
พ่อพ่อ
สามีพ่อสามี
พ่อคุณแม่ของเฮ็ดว่าอะไรคะแม่สามี
แม่สามีพ่อสามีระฆัง
จึงมีคำอื่นนะ
แต่พ่อสามีแม่สามีโอเคโอเคค่ะ S กับดี
เรียกนับอันนี้คุยให้ชื่ออะไรชื่อจีแล้ว
กันนะคะเรียกจิวะลูกสะใภ้ราคา
โอเคทีเป็นลูกสะใภ้นะคะอันนี้จิ
ผู้หญิงคะคะดีมี
มีลูก
มีลูก 1 คนเอาเกะกะลูกอะไรคะลูกสาว
มีลูกสาว 1 คน
ลูกสาวของ S  at อุ้ยดี
เรียกมิสเตอร์ S ว่าอะไรคะ
คุณปู่
ปู่คุณปู่โอเคใช่ค่ะลูกสาวของจี
เรียกมิสดีว่าอะไรคะ
คุณย่าคุณย่านะคะ
โอเคลูกสาวคนนี้นะลูกสาวคุยสีแดงหรือ
เปล่าลูกสาวน่ะ
เรียกทีว่าอะไรคะคุณป้าคุณป้า
เรียก
S ข้อนะคะ
ชื่ออะไรดี
เอ็ม
เอ็มเราก็โอเค
o  o  o เคดาห์อ่ะลูกสาวของ S เรียกฉี่
คุณป้าค่ะเรียกเกมว่าอะไรคะคุณอา
เรียกโอว่าอะไรคะคุณอาโอเค
ลูกของทีลูกของทีนะคะเรียก S ว่าอะไรคะ
คุณน้า
อะ
เรียก
M ว่าอะไรคะคุณน้าแล้วก็เรียก Go ว่า
อะไรคะคุณน้าโอเคไอ้คุยลบตรงนี้ก่อนเนาะ
ค่ะลายค่ะหน้าไปลบสีแดงออกก่อนนะคะพระเอก
เห็นลบรูปนี้ออกปั่นแวะเหนื่อยค่ะ
ลูก 2 คนมี
ลูก 2 คนผู้ชายผู้หญิงนะคะชอบไอเอ็มเอ็ม
ก็โตโตๆแล้วก็แต่งงาน
แต่งงาน
มีลูกไปคะมีลูก 1 คนเป็นผู้ชาย
มีลูกชาย 1 คน
ผู้หญิงลูกของ M
เรียกคุยใช้สีเขียวดีกว่าลูกของ M เรียก
ทีว่าอะไรคะคุณป้าคุณป้า
เรียก
S ว่าอะไรคะคุณลุง
เรียกโอว่าอะไรคะคุณน้าคุณน้านะคะโอเคก็
ขออีกนิดนึงเนอะนายค่ะ
ขอขยายนะคะ
ก็
โอเคอ่ะ o  o แต่งงานต่อ
โอ๊ะแต่งงานเหมือนกันอ่ะโอเคค่ะ OO แต่ง
งานอะคุยรถตรงนี้ป่ะ
โอมแต่เต้นๆแต่งงาน
โอมีลูก
กี่คนคะลูกชาย 1 คนค่ะ
ลูกชายของโอลูกชายของโอนะ
m
s แล้วก็ชีว่าอะไร
ที่รักคนๆเอะอะลูกชายของเหมือนกันเรียก M
แล้วก็ถี่ว่าอะไรคะคุณป้าคุณป้าลูกชายของ
โอ
เรียก S ว่าอะไรคะคุณลุงคุณลงราคา 1 ก็
งั้นภาษาไทยก็จะมีพ่อแม่
พ่อแม่
ลูก
พ่อพ่อแม่
ปู่ย่าตายาย
ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะกูอีกรถสีรถตัวเองทีนะผู้หญิง
ได้ค่ะคือตัวเองหรือไม่ลบนะคะค่ะขอเป็นรถ
ค้างหมดเลยๆอ่ะโอเคพ่อ
ถ้า
พ่อ
แม่พ่อแม่ก็มีพ่อ
แม่
พ่อแม่
ใช่ไหมคะค่ะอันนี้มีลูกค่ะพ่อแม่
ขอโทษค่ะ
พ่อแม่พ่อแม่ก็มีพี่ใช่ไหมคะได้พ่อแม่ก็
มีพี่ชายพี่สาว
พี่ชายพี่สาว
หน้าน้องชายน้องสาว
น้องชายน้องสาวเนาะอันนี้คือพ่อแม่ง
พ่อมีพ่อจะเลยค่ะพ่อแม่ก็คือกว่านี้พ่อ
แม่ลูกนะคะลูกก็จะมีมีแบบพ่อของพ่อคือคุณ
ปู่แม่ของพ่อคือคุณย่า
พ่อของแม่คุณตา
แม่ของแม่คุณยาย
พี่ชายพี่ชาย
ของพ่อกับแม่
คุณลุงที่สาวของพ่อกับแม่
คุณป้าคุณป้า
น้องน้องชายน้องสาว
ของพ่อกับแม่คุณอา
น้องสาวน้องน้องชายน้องสาวของคุณแม่คุณ
น้าถ้าน้องชายน้องสาวของพ่อคุณอาน้องชาย
น้องสาวของแม่คุณน้า
เด็กราคะ
ทุกคนตรงนี้
เรียกเด็กว่าอะไรคะ
หลานหลานนะคะเขาเควันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จัก
ปู่ย่าตายายพ่อพ่อแม่
ลุงป้าน้าอา
น้าาาโอเคใช่ค่ะเวลาใช่ไหมคะถ้าให้วันนี้
นักเรียนรู้จักครอบครัว
เราก็หมดเวลาแล้วจ่ายก็เดี๋ยวเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายฮือฮา